we're going to stay in the holiday
spirit here by heading over to tick tock
to see how they are celebrating
Christmas this year and uh if I know
anything about Tick Tock I think it'll
be very joyful and happy and uh also
deeply respectful to the Christmas
traditions so let's uh let's begin
[Music]
people off oh this definitely pisses
people off especially the majority of my
family
um when people say
um the reason for the season when
they're talking about Christmas and
they're all like the reason for this
season is Jesus
the reason for the season is Christian
propaganda
um I touched on this in one of my other
video rants but basically when the
Christians were like getting organized
or like look we got all these other
people that believe other things we
totally want them to believe what we
believe because like they have to
they basically said all right what do
they already celebrate let's just co-opt
that and change it so that instead of
worshiping like whatever like uh Heathen
gods that are worshiping they're going
to like substitute like Jesus and the
God Almighty Lord whatever and so they
did and that's why
um you know we have Christmas
uh which is Yule it's the winter
solstice all right so I can't even keep
watching that that's that really is
that's that's uh
that's a tough one that's a tough one to
listen to that
now
I wouldn't be surprised if
she was like a history professor at an
Ivy League school that that wouldn't
surprise me by the way she says that
that her take on this pisses people off
but see lady that that that no it
doesn't that's not the right word it's
it's the dumbest damn thing anyone's
ever heard you're saying very stupid
things and you're saying them very
stupid leads so you've got both things
going on here you're saying dumb things
you're saying them as dumbly as possible
and so it's not so people aren't upset
it's an it annoys them and I think
sometimes this is uh people can get
confused about this because they're not
they're not like offended or upset uh
that you've made some brilliant point
that they can't refute it's just that
you you really annoyed them
me much of the overlap between Christmas
and ancient Pagan festivals is invented
by internet memes that's what a lot of
it comes from but every single year it's
not even every year it's multiple times
a year when there's a big Christian
holiday you know namely uh Eastern
Christmas of course you have these
people on the internet who are very
satisfied with themselves and and think
of themselves as being very very
intelligent and they also think they're
the first ones to ever bring this up
this alleged connection between modern
Christian traditions and Pagan
Traditions you've always got there's a
million what is This Woman's name rise
Rebels
there's a million of her out there and
they think they're the first ones now
I'm going to tell you this is really
going to piss people off and then she
proceeds to say something we've all seen
in 50 million memes at this point
so a lot of that is made up it's an
urban legend that never happened some of
it isn't though so for instance pagans
for a long time used evergreen trees
and Evergreen plants in their
celebrations of the winter solstice
that's correct and if you wanted to you
could trace the Christmas tree back to
that and this is when you get the uh the
lefties as you see is originally Pagan
okay
fine what what's your point what do you
think that proves exactly what happened
is that as Pagan cultures became
Christian as they came to the faith they
didn't abandon all of their Traditions
their entire culture they didn't do that
they weren't required to
okay what exactly is the problem I don't
even understand what the problem is
supposed to be especially because by the
way almost all Traditions have if you
like Pagan Roots because if you want to
put it that way since if you go back far
enough almost everyone in the world was
pagan
if you go back far enough the vast
majority of the planet was pagan uh
let's keep going all right since it's
Christmas time let's talk about racism
and Christmas songs yeah you heard right
the term Eskimo appears in a couple
different Christmas songs and is
generally considered pretty offensive by
the Inuit people and by other groups
that live in the Arctic because it was a
word used by colonizers to describe
their people and imply that they were
barbaric and primitive I'm gonna give
you two examples of this words usage in
Christmas songs and I'll give you
suggestions for replacement lyrics too
we'll Frolic and play they ask him away
get rid of that
we'll finally can play the holiday wave
walk away better already
and the folks dressed up like
eskimo's everybody knows that we don't
like that and folks dressed up like in
snow globes everybody knows much better
merry Christmas don't be racist
uh
so a couple couple things here first
what we see again how the leftists on
Tick Tock think that they're blowing our
minds she says do you know there's
racist I'm going to tell you how some
regular Christmas songs are racist you
heard that right get ready for this so
yeah we know if we're watching a tick
tock video we know we're about to see
some white girl explain to us why
something totally innocuous is racist
you're not we we know that we know
that's where this is going immediately
you say that uh the word Eskimo that
Inuit people uh and and others who live
in the Arctic think that the word Eskimo
is
offensive here's a better plan rather
than replacing the word better plan is
for people who are offended by a totally
innocuous word like Eskimo to stop being
offended if there is anyone actually
offended by that better plan we could we
could change the songs or the other
solution is that if you're offended by
that just stop being offended or keep
being offended because honestly I don't
give a damn doesn't matter either way
uh you know what Eskimo actually means
you know the etymology of the word it
derives from French originally and uh it
means someone who wears a snowshoe or
someone who laces up a snowshoe that's
what it means the word is derived from
the fact that these people wore
snowshoes and so the Europeans who first
encountered them and didn't speak the
language they didn't know what they
referred to themselves as this is the
this is what they came up with why is it
offensive how is that derogatory just to
observe that someone's wearing a
snowshoe is a slur now hey take those
snow shoes off no I'd just like to
remind you again that the the people
this word applies to I guarantee you the
vast majority of them don't care at all
um all right let's keep going
[Music]
Jingle Bells
white supremacist systems will be
dismantled that's the unrealistic thing
she wants for Christmas it's actually
not unrealistic at all here's I've got
some good news for a change I can do I
can do you one better rather than
dismantling it for Christmas I could
tell you that it doesn't exist to begin
with there's nothing to dismantle it
doesn't it's a figment of your
imagination it's a phantom you've
invented it in your head it doesn't
exist so there you go that's that's my
Christmas present to you you're welcome
all right is there anyone is there
something a little bit more intelligent
something a little bit more uh I don't
know provocative hi I'm kale I don't
like Christmas very much last year I did
a series trying to like Christmas so
this year I said screw it I'm gonna do
anti-christmas tradition so we're making
cursed gingerbread men
I had to retake the shot anyways Slender
Man could be
she made cursed gingerbread man as her
anti-christmas tradition and the cursed
gingerbread men are like regular
gingerbread men but she uses green icing
instead of white that's some edgy stuff
watch out for the edge you might cut
yourself on this Edge now that's edgy as
[ __ ] uh I don't even feel right making
fun of this one because she's look she's
like probably 16 or something trying
desperately to be defiant and rebellious
and unfortunately you know this is this
is the situation kids are in these days
like we you know
we all went through phases when we were
kids we were really awkward phases of
trying to be rebellious and defiant
but many of us were older we had the
great Fortune of not having the ability
to capture all of this digitally and and
have it live forever on the internet
and so now for these kids this is going
to live forever which is uh really
unfortunate for her but the thing is
also here's a note kids if you want to
be rebellious and defiant and uh and and
all of that and you want to rebel and
and really be revolutionary around
Christmas time than just celebrate a
traditional joyful Christmas that's how
you can do it you can really set
yourself apart from your peers that way
Christmas you filthy animals all right
let's watch uh one more you know what
I'm already not looking forward to is
stop
but it's the people who get mad when I
say happy holidays at work they're like
Merry Christmas and I'm like oh yeah
happy holidays and Lily you can say
Christmas
and I'm just sitting here like
[Music]
I celebrate Yule I'm not I'm not
Christian I don't celebrate Christmas
and most of them are just like whatever
and they leave the store but then you
have the other half that are like you go
unless he's
please
leave me alone
you know what really pains me to say
this in some ways but in other ways
maybe I'm a uh relieved but I can say I
you know what I basically agree with you
right I actually kind of agree kind of
um because
there's actually nothing wrong now I
don't believe that that customers are
like screaming at her because she said
happy holidays instead of uh Merry
Christmas but there are some people who
make a big thing out of this and they
and they you know make this into part of
the war on Christmas is when cashiers at
Big Box retailers say happy holidays
instead of Merry Christmas and uh and I
do think that's an absurd thing to get
upset about either way it's fine it
doesn't you know if you say it to me
it's it's a it's a friendly greeting
around the holidays and I'm I'm fine
with that it's perfectly fine and you
know the other thing too
is that I think conservatives
need to take a cue from the left on this
point because the left they're very good
at co-opting things they know how to
co-opt and we go the opposite way you
know so as conservatives we hear happy
holidays and we say what no that's that
doesn't acknowledge Christmas instead we
should co-opt it which isn't even hard
to do it's not much of a stretch and
just say okay yeah happy holidays is the
same thing as saying Merry Christmas
that's what you're really saying you say
happy holidays what you really mean is
Merry Christmas and that's fine
so that way when someone tries to get
around Merry Christmas by saying happy
holidays they still haven't gotten
around it because they're still because
we've Co-op we've take taken ownership
of that phrase so rather than getting
offended by it or getting upset you
should take ownership of it
and so that no matter what you say
around the holidays you're still saying
Merry Christmas you see that's playing
chess instead of checkers even though
she found a very annoying way of putting
it I'm not going to disagree with this
young lady and uh maybe we'll end there
I just I didn't even think we'd get to
this point where I'd agree with one of
them but maybe we end there on a
positive note
and that's it Merry Christmas